xiomara castró la opción de izquierda
del partido libertad y refundación ya se
ha declarado ganadora de las elecciones
entre los vítores de sus seguidores
buena noche
[Aplausos]
porque voy
el pueblo se ha manifestado
y ha hecho para leer esa frase
solo el pueblo
la esposa del expresidente depuesto por
un golpe de estado en 2009 manuel zelaya
ha basado su campaña en la lucha contra
la corrupción y el narcotráfico
devolviendo el peso a la izquierda en el
país tras 12 años no obstante el partido
nacional con el continuista nasry asfura
como candidato también se autoproclamó
vencedor a pesar de su clara desventaja
vamos ganando nuestros movilizadores nos
informan que llevamos
1.225.000 nacionalistas registrados que
han votado por papel a la orden
cachurecos cuidemos y defendamos
nuestros votos estas elecciones han
estado marcadas por la alta
participación por encima del 68% un
récord para la nación centroamericana
algo que los expertos explican con el
rechazo al presidente juan orlando
hernández que termina su segundo mandato
en medio de acusaciones por corrupción y
conexiones con el narcotráfico y también
por el hartazgo de la población debido a
la crisis económica y el alto índice de
pobreza problemas que tendrá que
enfrentar la persona que finalmente
ocupe la presidencia del país